[Musique]
il y a un peu plus d'un an le 4 juillet
2015 les coteaux maison et CAF de
champagne ainsi que les climats de
Bourgogne étaient classés au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO avec les vignes de
Saint-Emilion dans le Bordelais inscrite
elle en 1999 ce sont trois des plus
grandes régions viticoles françaises qui
ont été honorés
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui dans le
prestigieux château d'Yquem considéré
comme le plus grand vin liquoreux au
monde
item voilà un nom qui fait rêver tout
comme Petrus et Margot ses voisins
bordelais Romanée conquis le roi Claude
Vougeot pour le vignoble de Bourgogne ou
encore
la Champagne aujourd'hui c'est leur
histoire que nous avons décidé de vous
raconter une histoire dans laquelle
s'entremêle des aventures humaines
exceptionnelles un savoir-faire
ancestral un art de vivre à la française
un patrimoine architectural hors du
commun car derrière ces étiquettes et
ses nectar de légende se cachent des
trésors unique au monde fruits de notre
culture et de notre histoire
[Musique]
ces trésors nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ceux qui les cultivent et
les préservent grâce à eux nous avons
découvert un patrimoine viticole aussi
riche que magique
elles font rayonner la France à
l'étranger depuis des siècles les
maisons de champagne les plus
prestigieuses nous ont tout vers leur
porte mais aussi délivrer leur secret il
y a pas un autre domaine dans le monde à
une autre propriété un autre château qui
n'a produit que 37 fois du vin en 100
ans
à plusieurs dizaines de mètres sous
terre nous avons eu rendez-vous avec la
grande histoire
et découvert de véritables chefs
[Musique]
à Bordeaux nous avons exhumé le
classement original des grands vins du
Médoc de 1855 et eu le privilège de
visiter tous les premiers crus classés
[Musique]
pour la première fois des caméras de
télévision ont été autorisées à pénétrer
au cœur du mythique et vénéré domaine de
Pomerol Pétrus je pense que la
sensibilité c'est la qualité la plus
importante que j'ai peut-être transmis à
mes fils
nous avons aussi rencontré Michel Jack
le propriétaire attachant d'un
patrimoine vertigineux une collection de
40000 flacons d'exception
il est vrai que là
vous avez ici la vitesse de ma famille
[Musique]
dans les coins zéro coin du légendaire
Château du Clos de Vougeot nous avons
effectué un véritable voyage dans le
temps tout à l'heure je parlais de magie
et bien nous y sommes en plein dans la
magie puisque nous sommes devant le
pressoir construit en 1477
[Musique]
enfin nous participerons avec les
artisans du Château d'Yquem à
l'élaboration très particulière du plus
illustre des vins liquoreux
[Musique]
première halte dans un lieu aussi
symbolique que prestigieux le palais de
l'Élysée
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré Virginie routisme
la première sommelière de la résidence
du chef de l'État elle nous a ouvert
exceptionnellement les portes d'une des
caves les plus secrètes et les plus
renommés au monde qui conservent pas
moins de 12.000 bouteilles
[Musique]
peu de personnes ont accès à la cave
c'est l'intendance et voilà même
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on rentre dans la
cabinisée
bien sûr les grandes étiquettes qui qui
sont les plus belles étiquettes les plus
beaux flacons ils sommeil
cette bouteille c'est la bouteille la
plus vieille de la cale c'est le château
rieuse 1906
par contre l'étiquette est un peu abîmée
mais mon prédécesseur a réussi
alors celle-ci normalement on ne sera
pas ouverte mise à part s'il y a une
demande du Président de la République
lui seul peut exiger de ces bouteilles
là oui en effet la seule personne qui
peut exiger dans
le gouverne les régions de France ils
sont bien sûr représentées avec
néanmoins une domination des vins de
Bordeaux de Bourgogne et de champagne
ce qui se comprend quand même
représenter la France mais moi j'ai
vraiment travaillé sur les autres
régions
représenter la France c'est l'une des
missions de Virginie lors des dînes
officielles ses meilleurs ambassadeurs
ce sont ces bouteilles
ouvrir énormément
du protocole sur un dîner d'État suivant
le mets on peut aller autant sur un
grand Bourgogne ou un grand Sauterne
suivant les accords de notre chef et
après c'est également les quantités
parce que un dîner d'État il y a quand
même 300 convives en général donc il
faut pouvoir avoir le nombre de
bouteilles qui
qui suivent pour 300 convives on va
sortir une trentaine de vin blanc une
quarantaine de vin rouge et en Champagne
pareil une quarantaine
[Musique]
parmi ces plus beaux souvenirs la
réception à l'Elysée de la reine
d'Angleterre à l'occasion des 70 ans du
débarquement de Normandie
là vraiment vraiment on avait servi des
très très beau vin c'était Château Yquem
97 et après je crois qu'on était sur un
Margot on avait également pour le clin
d'oeil pour la reine servi du Winston
Churchill en Champagne parce que voilà
c'est c'est le champagne vraiment
emblématique de la reine
ce soir là Virginie avait servi des vins
de légendes pour représenter la France
aux yeux du monde entier
je pense que c'est vraiment le 1 c'est
emblématique et on a cette chance en
France d'avoir vraiment le patrimoine
qu'il faut
ce patrimoine du vignoble français nous
l'avons arpenté à la recherche de ses
plus beaux trésors la cave de l'Élysée
refermée nous avons poussé les portes
des châteaux et domaines les plus
prestigieux à commencer par ceux de la
Champagne
[Musique]
35000 hectares de vigne 320 villages un
patrimoine architectural unique
[Musique]
des noms de légendes
le champagne symbole de fête et d'amour
fait rêver saliver les papilles du monde
entier
[Musique]
mais d'où vient-il ce champagne
commençons par tordre le cou à la
légende non l'illustre dont Pérignon
n'en est pas l'inventeur jusqu'à la fin
du 17e siècle la Champagne produit des
vins rouges à partir de raisins rouges
et des vins blancs à partir de raisins
blancs mais de piètre qualité alors pour
satisfaire et élargir leurs clientèle
quelques champenois visionnaires et
ingénieux dont la bédom Pérignon
conçoivent un vin totalement inédit et
de grande qualité ils assemble plusieurs
raisins issus de différents cépages de
différents crus et de différentes années
ils affinent sa vinification pour
maîtriser l'effervescence naturelle il
se fournissent en flacon mieux adapté à
la prise de mousse et fabrique des
bouchons hermétiques bref ils inventent
un vin nouveau qui va devenir l'un des
fleurons les plus éclatants de la France
à l'étranger
nous avons eu le privilège de pénétrer
dans l'une des maisons de champagne les
plus luxueuses mais aussi les plus
secrètes de Reims la maison chrome
4 lettres mythiques un vin considéré
comme la Rolls Royce du champagne un vin
qui année après année à la singularité
d'être
identique à celui imaginé par le
fondateur de la maison il y a plus de
170 ans
l'une de ces artisans c'est Julie CAVIL
ancienne publicitaire elle a tout quitté
il y a 15 ans pour accomplir son rêve
devenir
œnologue
c'était quelque chose d'un peu
inaccessible pour en plus quelqu'un qui
appartient à l'œnologie c'était vraiment
le Graal travailler chez Krug j'avais
cette image de qualité sans compromis
quand on regarde les notes qui sont
attribuées depuis 20 ans c'est toujours
des notes extraordinaires
extraordinaires et au moins je me dis
mais ça y est c'est incroyable ça fait
quatre ans que je rêve de ça j'avais
même pas imaginer et que ça puisse se
passer ici j'y suis
[Musique]
œnologue depuis maintenant 10 ans pas un
des recoins de la maison Krug n'a de
secret pour elle
Julie nous invite à découvrir la chambre
forte et nous voici dans l'âme de la
maison le cuvier des vins de réserve
[Musique]
alors ici on a tout ce qui fait
l'individualité de la maison on est dans
un lieu vraiment d'exception qui pour
nous est vraiment notre trésor pour
l'équipe onologie puisqu'ici vous voyez
que on a des petits contenants qui ont
été réalisés sur mesure pour épouser
parfaitement la forme de la voûte il
nous conservons les vins issus de 15 16
17 années de vendanges différentes
donc un vin il peut rester ici dans
cette bibliothèque finalement de vin de
réserve une année deux ans cinq ans dix
ans 15 ans ce sont ces précieux vins de
réserve associés au vins issues de
l'année en cours qui permettront de
retrouver le goût authentique déterminé
par le fondateur Joseph crew en 1843
[Musique]
il est 11h l'heure pour Julie de
déguster tous ses vins qui une fois
choisir assemblées élaboreront le
champagne grande cuvée
honnêtement ce qui m'a frappé quand je
suis arrivée à la maison c'est le nombre
de métiers de gestes de personnes qui
sont nécessaires pour élaborer nos cuvés
chez Krug il y a ceux qui sont experts
des fûts ce qu'il est visite ce qui les
sentent ceux qui les entonnent ceux qui
les marquent au pochoir ce qui les range
traditionnellement avec des cales qui a
un savoir-faire qui prend plus d'une
année et tous ces personnes là touchent
pas forcément le vin mais sont
totalement indispensables pour réaliser
élaborer nos cuvées
exceptionnellement Julie nous a autorisé
à assister à ce comité de dégustation
étape cruciale avant l'assemblage
alors voilà c'est aussi là que ça se
passe comme tous les jours à 11h le
comité de dégustation de la maison
crooks se réunit ici pour déguster 15
échantillons alors vous aimez mieux
c'est notre parcelle qu'on a à l'entrée
du Mesnil-sur-Oger au total Julie et le
comité devront choisir parmi les 150
vins de réserve et les 220 issus de
l'année en cours pour recréer le goût
originel de Krug tous ces vents étant
déguster 2 à 3 fois vous faites le
calcul plus le nombre de dégustateurs
autour de la table en général on traite
à peu près 4000 notes de dégustation
pour arriver à l'assemblage de la Grande
Cuvée la Grande Cuvée elle est recrée
toujours avec 10 11 12 13 années de
vendanges différentes entre 150 et 200
parcelles différentes et on dit qu'il
faut à peu près 20 ans pour élaborer une
seule bouteille de crowganctuel
20 ans pour élaborer une seule bouteille
entre 150 et 220 différents en un seul
flacon une patience et une exigence qui
justifie le caractère et le prix unique
de ce champagne
alors Maggie aujourd'hui Frédéric Le Bel
le chef de cave qui dirige comme tous
les jours la séance aujourd'hui sont
présents les membres du pôle œnologie
mais aussi les dirigeants de la maison
Olivier Krug et Margaret Enrique voilà
donc tout le monde est prêt les les
iPads sont calés c'est parti c'est bon
[Musique]
quelle note tu mets un peu écoute je
mets 14
Julie
mettre un bon 16 je trouve qu'il a un
élégant c'est une finesse un bord de
tête il est rasé donc dans l'assemblage
ça va vraiment élever
voilà
ça va relever le menton de ces
chardonnets c'est notes de dégustation
Julie les sauvegardes sur sa tablette
Eric quant à lui les conserves toujours
dans son grand livre noir il en possède
des dizaines et perpétueux ainsi la
tradition du fondateur Joseph Krug il
serait content je pense de voir notre
BlackBook Joseph il serait content de
voir que cette notion d'individualité
elle perdure toujours et que la maison
existe encore qu'à travers ça
c'est-à-dire
et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on
a construit
gardien de la maison nous entraîne dans
un salon privé qui abrite le livre
originel de Joseph Cruz un précieux
carnet conservé dans son écran
à la fin des années 70 mon grand-père a
retrouvé ce carnet qui avait été rangé
dans un coffre par son propre grand-père
presque un siècle plutôt et quand je
suis rentré dans la maison en 89 c'est
une des premières choses dont il m'a
parlé il m'a dit écoute Olivier un jour
il faudrait que tu lises ce carnet et
j'ai mis 25 ans à réouvrir ce carnet et
on a fait l'exercice collectivement il y
a 6 ou 7 ans et on est on est tous
tombés de notre chaise et le premier
être surpris c'était peut-être Eric
Lebel le chef de CAF parce que quand on
lit ce carnet en commun il découvre de
façon très très claire très précise les
gestes que lui fait tous les jours qu'il
a appris de mon papa des anciens etc 170
ans plus tard il est clair que crew
correspond au rêve que Joseph avait en
tête quand il a tout quitté à l'âge de
42 ans pour créer un type de champagne
qui n'existait pas
le véritable trésor de la maison il est
probablement là dans cette transmission
cet échange entre les générations et les
métiers aujourd'hui Julie en est l'une
des plus authentiques héritières voyez
ici vous avez des années et des années
de vendanges l'idée est de transmettre
justement ça au futur générations donc
on est là au milieu il faut rester très
très avec beaucoup au four faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité à l’œnologie puisque
on est vraiment c'est pasteur ce témoin
entre ce devoir de mémoire
du patrimoine de la maison et puis ce
devoir aussi de transmission pour les
futurs générations
dénicher ses trésors du vignoble de
Champagne c'est allé à la rencontre de
passionnés de véritables artisans d'art
qui mettent leur savoir-faire et leur
excellence au service de notre
patrimoine culturel
mais c'est aussi voyager à travers les
siècles et les continents
[Musique]
son nom évoque un certain art de vivre à
la française il est le deuxième
champagne le plus vendu dans le monde et
illumine depuis bientôt 250 ans les
réceptions les plus fastueuses le
champagne Veuve Clicquot nous avons pu
accéder aux arcanes de la maison pour
découvrir comment ce champagne a
représenté la France aux quatre coins de
la planète pendant plus de deux siècles
Fabienne Moreau en charge du patrimoine
de la maison nous a ouvert les portes
des archives on est dans un lieu
exceptionnel puisque c'est là qu'on
conserve l'ensemble des archives de la
maison Veuve Clicquot depuis la date de
la fondation en 1772 jusqu'à 1950 à peu
près
c'est en exhumant ses archives rares que
nous avons découvert le destin de celle
qui est à l'origine de ce succès
barbe Nicole Ponsardin une bourgeoise de
Reims devenue veuve à 27 ans et qui va
avoir l'audace de reprendre les rênes de
la maison familiale fondée par son
beau-père Philippe Clicquot on est en
1805 on est pendant une période
extrêmement troublée en Europe ce sont
les guerres napoléoniennes les récoltes
n'ont pas été extraordinaires du tout
dans les années qui précèdent et là on
découvre un personnage extraordinaire de
détermination d'intelligence de vision
parce que on est à une époque où le
champagne c'est encore un produit un peu
expérimental ensuite elle va vraiment
s'attacher à la qualité des vins elle
essayait de comprendre ce qui se passe
et on lui doit des progrès vraiment
significatifs en termes d'élaboration du
champagne que l'on que l'on utilise
toujours aujourd'hui c'est elle qui
invente la technique de remuage des
bouteilles sur une une table puis sur
des pupitres et c'est un moment décisif
pour pour la Champagne
et ensuite et c'est très important elle
va faire preuve d'une grande tenacité
pour exporter ses dents
la France est un marché extrêmement
restreint le champagne est déjà un
produit de luxe difficile à élaborer il
coûte cher la première femme à diriger
une maison de champagne décide alors
d'élargir ses horizons de vente première
escale la Russie
on a une vraie francophilie chez les
chez les consommateurs les amateurs
russes et la consommation de champagne
va avec l'amour des belles lettres
françaises avec les plaisirs d'avoir des
beaux objets des beaux tableaux venant
de France la littérature etc donc c'est
un tout un art de vivre qui s'exporte à
travers une bouteille de champagne
de l'Europe du Sud à la Russie en
passant même par la Laponie son
champagne conquiert dès le 19e siècle le
monde entier
femme moderne et déterminée la veuve
clicone n'a qu'un objectif participé à
la grandeur de la France
[Musique]
alors nous avons un document
exceptionnel c'est vraiment une pépite
dans notre trésor de des archives il
s'agit d'un document plus personnel donc
sur lequel est écrit le nom de Madame
Picot nous l'avions pas dans nos
archives c'est une personne qui l'a
trouvé dans un grenier d'un château qui
devenait d'acheter
Nelly encore vraiment son activité au
sein du vignoble d'achat de raisin de
négoce de produits liés à la vigne et
puis c'est vrai que je vous disais qu'il
y avait beaucoup d'émotions parce que on
est là sur la date d'avril 1866 et donc
on est quelques mois avant sa
disparition
on a là certainement les derniers écrits
de Madame Picot
dame de fer la Veuve Clicquot n'en
restait pas moins une dame de cœur
humaniste elle fonda des écoles une
maison de retraite et dans son château
de Boursault près d'Épernay elle créera
une caisse de secours un château dans
lequel elle s'éteindra à 89 ans
[Musique]
la maison de champagne perpétuera ses
valeurs tout au long du XXe siècle
Fabienne Moreau nous invite à les
découvrir dans un endroit tout à fait
mystérieux à plusieurs dizaines de
mètres sous terre
[Musique]
ici on se trouve dans les crières de la
maison Veuve clico c'est un endroit
emblématique pour l'histoire de Reims
pour l'histoire du champagne pour
l'histoire de la maison parce que on y
trouve vraiment les éléments liés au
patrimoine donc les premières crières
ont été creusées à l'époque
gallo-romaine à Reims les blocs de craie
étaient extraits pour pouvoir construire
les remparts qui fortifiaient la ville
celle où on se trouve aujourd'hui et
bien sont plus du Moyen-Âge du 11ème
12ème siècle et elles ont été donc
abandonnées une fois la carrière creusée
et c'est seulement au 19e siècle et au
début du 20e siècle pour la maison Veuve
Clicquot que on a réinvesti les lieux
les Crayères de la butte saint Nicaise
avec leur obscurité leur tranquillité et
leur température constante de 11 degrés
sont un endroit idéal pour la maturation
du champagne ce sont donc des milliers
d'employés qui vont travailler dans ces
24 kilomètres de galeries comme en
témoignent ces insolites plaques
patronymiques
en fait c'est vraiment un hommage rendu
à la fidélité de ces personnes de la
maison donc la plaque porte le nom de ce
salarié de sa date d'entrer sa date de
sortie dans la maison et le dernier
métier qu'il a exercé parce que
généralement un jeune peut rentrer à 14
ans et est terminé sa carrière comme
chef d'atelier chef bouchonnier renouer
[Musique]
mais en 1914 la ville de Reims est
bombardée aux côtés de civil et de
soldats ses employés se retrouvent à un
véritable carrefour de l'histoire de
France
on est face à des traces de l'histoire
de l'histoire de la grande guerre on y
voit là une Croix-Rouge avec une flèche
ça c'est des traces de peinture qui
datent du début de la Première Guerre
mondiale et qui permettait donc aux
personnes qui arrivaient dans les caves
de s'orienter pour aller soit vers
l'infirmerie soit s'abriter puisqu'ici
on lit aussi on devine les lettres qui
forment le mot abri
des noms des dates de naissance
la Grande Guerre écrira aussi une page
de son histoire douloureuse dans ses
crières de champagne
c'est une vraie émotion de pouvoir aussi
conserver les traces de cette histoire
quand on traverse ses crières et bien on
sent en effet que on efface à un
patrimoine qui qui dépasse évidemment la
ville de Reims
véritable cathédrale souterraine les
Crayères de la butte Saint-Nicaise
abrite de multiples trésors de notre
histoire
sous l'impulsion d'une autre grande dame
de la Champagne le vin se fait alors
œuvre d'art
à quelques centaines de mètres des
Crayères de la maison Veuve Clicquot
Luis Pommery architecte du vin et des
pierres transforment à la fin du 19e
siècle ses 18 km de galeries en galerie
d'art
Gustave naveley sculpte a même la craie
et à la bougie plusieurs bas-reliefs
tous à la gloire du champagne
[Musique]
en s'enfonçant dans les galeries on y
découvre une œuvre plus imposante un
souper sous la région
[Musique]
mais le plus impressionnant peut-être
c'est ce bas-relief Silène représentant
le père adoptif de Bacchus un bas-relief
sculpté en 1884 de plus de 15 mètres de
long sur 6 mètres de haut
[Musique]
des trésors le patrimoine du vignoble
champenois en regorge mais il arrive que
certains d'entre eux soient plus connus
à l'étranger que sur notre territoire
c'est le cas de la maison salon
[Musique]
en plein cœur du village du
Mesnil-sur-Oger une parcelle de vigne et
l'objet de toutes les attentions cette
parcelle c'est vraiment l'origine le
patrimoine de salon c'est ce qui fait
salon au début de tout avant même de
consommer les bouteilles tout part d'ici
c'est notre richesse notre richesse
c'est la terre
cet homme est pris de cette terre c'est
Didier de pont tour enjaux de souche il
est à la tête depuis 20 ans de la
prestigieuse et très confidentielle
maison de champagne Salon est un
champagne très discret dans le monde du
champagne on nous voit très peu on parle
très peu de nous et donc on est
également très discret sur les gens qui
consomment salon et nos clients mais
effectivement il y a des gens très
célèbres aussi bien du cinéma du théâtre
de la musique qui sont qui sont nos
clientes salons fait partie de ces cinq
six vins divins peut-être dans le monde
qui sont recherchés par les
collectionneurs et que l'on trouve
également dans les ventes aux enchères à
des prix qui s'envolent totalement
salon est unique en Champagne par son
prix aucune bouteille n'est vendu à
moins de 400 euros mais surtout par son
absence d'assemblage c'est un
monothéraire la Côte des Blancs un mono
cru le village du Mesnil-sur-Oger un
mono cépage du Chardonnay un mono
millésime les vins d'une seule année
[Musique]
aux côtés de Didier Depont nous allons
faire partie des rares privilégiés à
découvrir les secrets de cette légende
de la Champagne une légende créée par un
homme en 1905 Eugène et mes salons
monsieur salon a dit je ne vais faire du
champagne qu'à base de Chardonnay c'est
le créateur du blanc de blanc
Chardonnay venant d'un seul cru d'un
seul village le Mesnil-sur-Oger là où on
se trouve aujourd'hui et je ne ferai du
champagne je ne produirai du champagne
uniquement lorsque ça sera un très grand
une très grande année à millésime sinon
je ne ferai rien
au 20e siècle salon n'a produit que 37
millésimes en 100 ans
[Musique]
il y a pas un autre domaine dans le
monde à une autre propriété un autre
château dans le dans le monde qui n'a
produit que 37 fois du vin en 100 ans et
puis pour corser encore un petit peu
l'affaire monsieur salon a dit je vais
garder mes vins les faire vieillir dans
la cave minimum 10 ans
on peut imaginer que si on fait un
millésime 2016 il sera disponible en
2030 effectivement
salon a créé le premier champagne de
garde un champagne qui se déguste avec
parcimonie pas plus de 60 000 bouteilles
sont produites par an
ils sont donc rares ceux qui ont déjà
goûté ce champagne d'exception
aujourd'hui Didier on a invité certains
à déguster quelques millésimes
ses amis comme Didier les appels sont
indonésiens chinois ou encore américain
des amis qui n'hésitent pas à faire des
milliers de kilomètres pour goûter une
nouvelle fois ce champagne au goût très
vineux qu'il considère unique
Didier a organisé un déjeuner servi dans
un des salons de la maison
nous avons rencontré Félix qui vient de
Pékin il a fait plus de 8000 km pour
venir au Mesnil-sur-Oger
du vin en fait on aime tous le vin la
façon de vivre à la fin à la française
la chambre
par sa qualité la recherche de la pureté
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on trouve
pas d'autre champagne Salon de plus en
plus connu en Chine maintenant on le
qualifie comme
soi-disant le Hermès de Chambéry
Ariel quant à lui est argentin son
premier souvenir avec salon il s'en
rappelle comme si c'était hier c'était
une découverte extraordinaire
on sait qui on aime un produit qui est
fait d'une manière particulière et
certains caractéristiques qui sont
propres au champagne
[Musique]
salon aujourd'hui c'est le résultat pas
seulement de la recherche des excellence
de qualité du vivant mais c'est aussi le
respect des cette tradition et pour pour
venir déguster ça c'est je crois que ça
vaut la peine n'importe quel voyage en
fait
la tradition dont parle Ariel nous
l'avons découverte lorsque nous avons
délaissé les hôtes de Didier le temps du
déjeuner
au détour d'une cave nous avons croisé
Jérémy
ce jour-là il était en charge du remuage
une étape qu'il réalise comme autrefois
consiste à remuer les bouteilles tous
les jours pour faire descendre le dépôt
par gravité pour que le dépôt revienne
se loger dans le goût de la bouteille
d'un petit bidule en plastique qui est
après ensuite à la fin du roméage sera
dégorgé manuellement
par jour Jérémy peut remuer jusqu'à 50
000 bouteilles
je parle avec mes amis c'est que j'ai la
chance de oui j'ai envie des bouteilles
qui sont assez exceptionnels et puis qui
sont pas la portée de tout le monde au
niveau achat
une fois remuée Jérémie devra pratiquer
le dégorgement à la volée comme
autrefois
était fini trois semaines que la
bouteille a été remuée donc toujours le
goulot vers le bas on va placer la pince
juste devant la capsule
on tape un petit peu la bulle que j'ai
oublié
pour qu'il qu'une bulle au cul de la
bouteille et la tranquillement on va
venir monter faire monter la bulle et là
et là on évacuer toute la boucle qui est
dans la bouteille et là c'est un truc
une bouteille claire
une élaboration traditionnelle et unique
qui séduit donc les amateurs bien
au-delà de nos frontières
[Musique]
à l'étage le repas s'achève comblé les
invités remercies chaleureusement leur
route salut Félix merci beaucoup à
bientôt à bientôt ciao merci c'était un
grand moment un grand moment de partage
parce que quand on fait le les vins que
nous faisons en fait nous les faisons
pour les partager on a entendu le son
qui montait des gens des gens heureux
des gens souriants et des gens qui
repartent avec une idée une belle idée
de la Champagne une belle idée de salon
une belle idée de la France
salon une légende méconnue devenue
pourtant l'un des fleurons du patrimoine
viticole français
[Musique]
c'est parti pour la vendange oui
Francis Mayer nous sommes de retour dans
les magnifiques vignes de Château d'Yves
c'est un jour vraiment très particulier
parce que ce sont les vendanges ici à
Château d'Yquem et ce sont des vendanges
très particulières parce que vous faites
pas à la vendanges comme tout le monde
si j'ose dire vous vous attendez un
petit champignon de quel champignon
s'agit-il très commun c'est un des plus
grands ravageurs de la ville c'est le
botritis cinerea chez nous à Sauternes
peut arriver à ce stade extraordinaire
de pourriture noble justement de raisin
confits pourquoi parce que l'eau s'étend
évaporée le sucre concentré on va
arriver à un potentiel de 20 21 degrés
d'alcool et c'est le degré dont on a
besoin pour faire du sauter
alors du coup c'est c'est récolte vous
oblige j'imagine à avoir un rendement
très faible le rendement au final
extrêmement faible à ikem on produit en
fait un verre de vin par pied de vigne
c'est ce grain rôti que vous allez
vendanger pour vous ça c'est la
perfection
culte quand certains sont prêts à
parcourir des milliers de kilomètres
pour venir déguster quelques centilitres
de ce précieux nectar d'autres sont
prêts à investir toutes leurs économies
pour acquérir un flacon un souvenir une
histoire
cette quête des plus beaux trésors du
vignoble français ne nous a pas conduit
uniquement dans les plus beaux châteaux
ou palais de la République
à 70 km de Niort en race campagne Michel
Jack chasseur un retraité de 75 ans
ne détient
fils de facteurs Michel Jack a très vite
été contaminé par la fièvre
collectionneuse les timbres bien sûr
puis très vite sont venus s'ajouter les
vins
tout commence réellement dans les années
60 entrez chez Dassault comme
chaudronnier quelques années plus tard
il est chargé d'accueillir les
délégations étrangères une mission qui
lui permet de découvrir le vin les
grands vins
et j'ai commencé par acheter tout ce qui
était le plus rare comme m'avait dit
Marcel Dassault des petits vins vous ont
trouvé tous les jours mais des vins
rares il vaut mieux une bouteille que
sans bouteille et c'est ce que j'ai fait
ce qui a permis à ce que cette
collection de mienne unique au monde
une collection unique au monde que
Michel jack décide en l'an 2000 de
protéger
qui se trouve la source volière pourquoi
c'est des volières c'est parce que vous
avez les entrées d'aération
derrière ces filets sous ces drôles de
cheminée à quelques mètres sous terre
des poulaillers se cache l'une des plus
belles caves du monde
j'ai commandé 3000 par Paris et en août
en 2000 je me suis pris par la main 5
mètres par jour j'ai construit ma cave
et puis ça fait un blockhaus en terre de
30 mètres de long sur 5 mètres de large
[Musique]
Michel Jack a accepté de nous faire
découvrir son sanctuaire comme il
l'appelle mais pour y accéder il faut
s'armer de patience et de vigilance
après avoir descendu un abrupte
d'escalier évitez les pièges que Michel
Jacky a placé
traverser une cave ouvert une porte
blindée
démontez un mur de parpaing
traversez une nouvelle cave et emprunter
un obscur tunnel
[Musique]
nous avons pu enfin pénétrer dans le
saint des saints
[Musique]
nous voici dans le sanctuaire des vins
mythiques des plus gros vins du monde
dans les plus grands millésimes des vins
le plus grands de tous les temps
[Musique]
vous avez les grands champagnes salon
les vins de la vallée du Rhône là vous
avez tous les grandes
Châteauneuf-du-Pape château raillas
Henri Bono ensuite nous arrivons vers la
Bourgogne les monts tous les tous les
morrachiders
[Musique]
en face vous avez les grands vins de
Bordeaux premier grand cru classé 1855
mouton Margot a fait tout brillant dans
les grands millésimes 61 82 90 2000-2005
et j'ai par exemple un siècle d'icam de
1900 jusqu'à nos jours dans les plus
vieux millésimés 111
1847-1921 à la mythique et parallèlement
au grand blanc liquoreux tous les Pétrus
depuis 1945
[Musique]
j'ai goûté
de pain dans les années 1970
au total Michel Jack a rassemblé plus de
40 000 bouteilles
estimez à 40 millions d'euros et
derrière chacune de ces bouteilles
derrière chaque millésime Michel Jack a
une histoire à raconter
bateau Titanic et effectivement à cette
époque tous ces milliardaires étaient
partis dans ce bateau avec les coffres
les bijoux tout ce qu'ils avaient plus
cher le plus riche entre eux et le soir
parmi les festivités voilà ils buvait de
l'or ça veut dire que ils avaient pris
tous leurs beaux bijoux reflétant dans
les lustres du bateau et avec tout ça
dans des couples à champagne et buvet de
la barre et Brisard avec des petites
paillettes d'or qui flottent
[Musique]
et en buvet de l'or à l'époque c'était
le raffinement suprême purificateur de
sang
[Musique]
il y a aussi ce gruau la rose retrouvé
dans une épave échouée en mer de Chine
en 1872 ou encore ce Pétrus 1914
[Musique]
il est vrai que là
vous avez ici la vitesse de ma famille
mon grand-père qui a fait la guerre 14
là j'ai tous les écrits au crayon de
papier dans les tranchées Verdun avec ça
les gens toutes ces militaires
il était cafetière essence quatre mon
père facteur qui paye le monde
aujourd'hui en musique
et c'est vrai c'est peut-être grâce à
cette famille à mes parents que je suis
là aujourd'hui en toute simplicité
humble que finalement tout est possible
sur terre si on a la volonté
et pour le rendre hommage j'ai donc
trouvé
les deux amis
Château Yquem et Petrus 1914 car mon
père est né en 1914
tous les murs de la cave de Michel Jack
sont recouverts de nom de légendes alors
forcément sa collection attire la
convoitise des plus grands amateurs du
monde entier
de 400 personnes et à côté de moi
j'avais un chinois qui gagnait un
million d'euros par jour alors
effectivement la fin du repas je vois ce
monsieur qui sort son canapé qui me fait
un chèque 50 millions d'euros alors je
dis à mon collègue monsieur Cointreau
qui m'a fait à l'époque c'est quoi il me
dit Monsieur c'est pour ta collection ta
collection 50 millions d'euros mais je
dis la collection n'est pas à vendre
c'est un patrimoine est-ce qu'elle a
Joconde à vendre non la collection même
pour 50 millions d'euros
à l'instar de la Joconde Michel Jack
considère ces bouteilles comme des
oeuvres d'art sa collection comme le
chef-d'œuvre d'une vie
c'est le patrimoine pour les générations
futurs qui doit être conservé et qui ne
peut pas être considéré comme collection
parce que collection c'est trop
patient très privé personnel j'ai une
collection à ce qui me concerne
cette sera toutes ces caisses
rassemblées c'est le patrimoine de
l'Unesco qui appartient au monde entier
ce patrimoine Michel Jack aimerait le
partager en érigeant un Louvre du vin un
projet ambitieux pour sauvegarder un
véritable trésor national
[Musique]
abandonnant Michel Jack à ses rêves nous
avons repris notre route pour partir
cette fois à la découverte des trésors
du vignoble bordelais
[Musique]
pour commencer un peu d'histoire si la
présence de vignes dans la région
remonte à l'Antiquité ce n'est qu'au 18e
siècle que vont s'affirmer les grands
vins de Bordeaux
révolue le temps de ce vin coupé à l'eau
vendu en barrique et que développait dès
le 12ème siècle Aliénor duchesse
d'Aquitaine et reine d'Angleterre
au XVIIIe siècle place à la splendeur à
la qualité et à la bouteille en verre
idéal pour bonifier les vins et offrir
toute leur noblesse
des nouveaux vins qui font une entrée
retentissante à la cour de Louis XV on
se déplace même de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique pour déguster et élire ces
vins bordelais préférés en 1787 le futur
troisième président américain Thomas
Jefferson en visite dans la région tombe
littéralement sous le charme enivrant de
80 Château Margaux château Lafitte
Château Latour et Château Haut-Brion
c'était sans le savoir anticipé sur un
classement qui serait établi seulement
en 1855 et qui de nos jours continuent
de faire référence
[Musique]
ce classement que tous les amateurs de
20 aujourd'hui connaissent c'est le
classement des grands crus du Médoc
édifiés par Napoléon III en 1855
à cette époque l'empereur avait souhaité
pour la première exposition universelle
française la présence de grands crus
qu'il considérait comme des fleons de
l'excellence nationale
un document historique et mythique donc
conservé à la Chambre de Commerce de
Bordeaux et que nous présente max de
l'estapi président honoraire du syndicat
des courtiers
c'est émouvant parce que j'ai dans mes
mains la lettre du syndic et des
adjoints donc des courtiers de commerce
de la Bourse de Bordeaux qui répondent à
au membre de la Chambre de commerce
qu'il avait confié une mission donc la
mission de faire cette classification
ce sont des documents émouvants puisque
quand même une date du 18 avril 1855 oui
cela peut paraître surprenant mais ce
sont bien des courtiers qui ont observé
les prix du marché et classer les vents
par niveau économique sans aucun critère
qualitatif
[Musique]
la classification a été rapidement faite
elle a été faite en l'espace d'une
quinzaine de jours
alors ici vous avez la liste des
premiers crus
la liste des 2e crues
la liste des 3e crues et des quatrième
et des 5e crues voilà en tout 61 cru ont
été classés
[Musique]
les quatre châteaux classés premiers
sont Lafitte Margaux Latour et au Brion
aubryon un vignoble connu pour être l'un
des plus anciens de la région bordelaise
de par ce classement il est aussi l'un
des plus prestigieux
aux côtés de son actuel propriétaire le
prince Robert de Luxembourg nous avons
découvert les secrets de s'allongevité
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que aubryon
vignoble le plus ancien de la région
pense qu'il y a eu des vignes ici
plantées entre 40 et 60 après
Jésus-Christ et il y a beaucoup de
familles qui se sont suivies bien celles
qui a le plus marqué l'histoire de
clairement c'est les contacts
pentac un nom qui va marquer l'histoire
des plus grands vins de Bordeaux a
commencé par son domaine bien sûr
à la fin du 17e siècle à une époque où
tant de guerre font rage il faut pouvoir
stocker le vin Arnaud III de Pontacq
fait alors la synthèse de différentes
techniques et invente ce que l'on
appelle aujourd'hui les vins de garde
[Musique]
avant celle-là
du style que nous avons d'ailleurs
toujours ici à Bordeaux aujourd'hui
c'était une façon je pense de protéger
le vin et aussi de mettre l'accent sur
des vins tels que les vins d'eau
bruyants qui étaient vraiment marqué par
une qualité à part
à titre exceptionnel le prince Robert de
Luxembourg nous a autorisé à découvrir
ces techniques toujours utilisées trois
siècles plus tard dans le chai du
Château Haut-Brion
la première d'entre elles le brûlage du
soufre pour assainir les barriques
puis le soutirage qui en transvasant le
vin le débarrasse de ses impuretés
enfin louillage qui consiste à compenser
l'évaporation en remplissant constamment
les barriques pour éviter que le vin ne
s'oxyde
[Musique]
ce carnotroix de Pontac invente ce sont
tout simplement les vins d'aujourd'hui
son fils inauvra son tour en inventant
le concept de château viticole pour la
première fois un vin portent le nom d'un
terroir dans les restaurants dans les
commerces on parle désormais de Château
Haut-Brion
par cela et peut-être la première marque
de luxe du monde
la notoriété internationale du père des
Premiers Crus Classés étantché et
perdure 3 siècles plus tard
certains millésimes de Château
Haut-Brion peuvent aujourd'hui
s'échanger après de 3000 euros
[Musique]
des idées révolutionnaires qui
accompagnent des vins extraordinaires
voilà aussi une des raisons de l'ancrage
de ses breuvages dans notre histoire
à Château Margaux autre cru distingués
par le classement de 1855 c'est un
savoir-faire unique qui honore ce nectar
nous avons rencontré sa propriétaire
Corinne Menzel au boulot qui a pris les
reines du château il y a plus de 30 ans
j'avais une licence de lettres classique
et j'avais fait Sciences Po en économie
et finance j'avais une petite
justification mais je n'y connaissais
rien au vin c'est que je me suis pas
rendu compte de l'enjeu c'est pour ça
que je l'ai pris à bras le corps ça
serait à refaire aujourd'hui j'aurais
peut-être plus de
recul ou
d'hésitation c'est difficile à savoir
son investissement Corinne le tient de
son père André Menzel opoulos riche
entrepreneur grec qui en 1977 acquiert
un château et des vignes délaissées dont
à l'époque personne ne veut
première ambition rendre à la bâtisse
son lustres dont on dans le plus pur
respect des techniques traditionnelles
ils ont su choisir un architecte des
monuments historiques assez doué mais
surtout très amoureux des vieilles
pierres
le résultat est à la hauteur des travaux
engagés aujourd'hui le château de style
néoclassique est considéré comme le
Versailles du Médoc
[Musique]
André mezzellopoulos s'attaque ensuite
au vignes et en quelques années
seulement leur restitue toute leur
grandeur
il s'agissait pas de d'améliorer il
s'agissait de remettre Margot à son
niveau qu'il avait perdu à cause des
grands millésimes et du manque
d'investissement
héritière et véritable ambassadrice du
Château Margaux Corinne menzello poulos
porte ses crues de légende jusqu'au plus
grande table de la planète
vous êtes au service de Château Margaux
c'est pas Château Margaux qui qui vous
rend service ou qui c'est nous qui
sommes obligés d'être dans sa longue
histoire un petit bout finalement nous
passons par hasard et si je peux dire
au moment de partir j'espère le plus
tard possible que je n'ai pas failli à
cette tâche que en tout cas je ne l'ai
pas abîmée parce que l'améliorer est-ce
qu'on peut encore je ne sais pas
un passage éphémère pour rendre un vin
éternel le défi quotidien de Corinne
menzellopoulos et colossale
pour mener à bien cette tâche Corinne
s'entoure d'une équipe de véritables
passionnés
depuis 4 ans maintenant
Jonathan Ribéra et le Tonnellier maison
ou plutôt château
à 38 ans il est l'un des derniers
tonneliers à travailler au sein même
d'un château viticole
quand j'avais 17 ans j'ai mis les pieds
dans une tonnellerie et j'ai pu voulu en
repartir et on devient tonolier par par
amour du métier
on ne devient pas tout nuée par hasard
ici j'ai la chance de pouvoir travailler
les barriques quasiment comme ça se
faisait il y a 200 ans ici c'est quand
même une chance pour la tolérer
française de pouvoir conserver un métier
totalement artisanal
de conserver les valeurs de ce métier là
et toute la technique qui va avec
son atelier est un endroit un peu hors
du temps avec ses odeurs surannées et
ses outils d'autrefois
ma première étape est de sélectionner et
d'installer une planche qui va
déterminer la mesure exacte de la
barrique donc tout le travail va être de
déterminer l'emplacement exemple des
douelles
les duels étant des planches de chêne
qui ont été séchées entre 24 et 36 mois
Jonathan le connaît sous toutes ses
rainures
d'une certaine sensualité entre le
tonnelier et le bois qui travaille le
contact du bois est
très doux c'est une matière noble
[Musique]
de s'imaginer que ce bois là est
peut-être bicentenaire
les duels posées Jonathan les rassemble
dans des cercles de montage en véritable
homme orchestre il prépare alors à
l'aide d'une chasse et d'un marteau ce
qu'on appelle une rose
mais tout son savoir-faire Jonathan va
l'exprimer dans une prochaine étape
nécessaire pour la qualité du vin la
chauffe
la chauffe et le moment le plus
important de la réalisation d'une
barrique c'est la chose qui va qui va
révéler les tanins du bois et suivant
l'intensité de chauffe on va obtenir un
impact différent sur le vin qui sera
dedans
tonnelier ou quand travailler le bois
devient travailler le vin
je réalise une chauffe qui était
déterminé par le maître de chez par
rapport au travail qui veut réaliser sur
les valeurs
on peut obtenir des odeurs de Moka il
peut y avoir des goûts toastés
une chauffe légère peut ramener des
choses beaucoup plus douces beaucoup
plus feutres
des odeurs de pain grillé
donc à l'aide du Capestang qui est au
sol je vais resserrer la barrée au fur
et à mesure de sa montée en température
après une heure 15 de chauffe
Jonathan devra rendre l'étanchéité du
fût en lui apposant ses fonds
[Musique]
en une journée il réussira à fabriquer
deux barriques
protecteur de cette tradition Jonathan
espère bien son tour transmettent ce
savoir-faire séculaire et contribuer
ainsi au prestige de Château Margaux
[Musique]
bonjour Sandrine bonjour Sophie j'ai
l'impression de vous déranger non non
je suis concentrée je suis ça à Sandrine
garbaï vous êtes maître de chez ici à
Château d'Yquem et là c'est une
opération de surveillance de contrôle
que sont-ils tout à fait nous sommes ici
dans le chez souterrain où nous avons le
millésime 2015 qui est en élevage et
donc je suis en train en fait de
contrôler chaque barrique pour vérifier
que tout va bien que l'élevage se passe
bien
alors est-ce que là tout va bien tout va
bien vous regardez la couleur je regarde
la couleur en fait l'aspect il faut
évidemment que le vin soit lempy des
calmes donc sans pétillement aucun
évidemment et le nez doit être
aromatique intense très fruité vraiment
sur un fruit pur et net ce qui est le
cas ici sur ce 2015
je peux
ce travail est cette tradition était
récompensés dès 1855 par le classement
de Napoléon III Kem devient alors le
premier et unique vin blanc à être
classé premier Cru Supérieur
ICEM côtoie alors ces illustres voisins
du Médoc
[Musique]
notre chasse au trésor dans le vignoble
bordelais se poursuit avec en guise de
carte routière de luxe ce fameux
classement de 1855 après aubryon et
Margaux nous nous sommes arrêtés un
instant dans les trois autres premiers
grands crus classés de Bordeaux
Château Latour et son vignoble de 750
000 pieds au bord de la Gironde
château Lafitte Rothschild dont le
château du 16e siècle est classé
monument historique
[Musique]
et puis Mouton Rothschild seul château
ayant intégré le haut du classement
après 1855
mais comme souvent dans les trajets ce
sont les détours les petits imprévus qui
offrent des souvenirs impérissables
non classé en 1855 et pour cause il
n'est pas situé en Médoc mais à Pomerol
courtisé vénéré même il est l'un des
portes étendard de ce que la France
offre de plus raffinés à l'étranger
fermé au visite jamais exposé aux
caméras de télévision
son domaine nous a été
exceptionnellement ouvert
Pétrus
[Musique]
c'est Olivier Berrouet sont tout jeunes
directeur qui détient les clés de ce
trait discret paradis dont la boisson
divine a fasciné tous ceux qui ont eu le
privilège de la déguster
alors Pétrus c'est une histoire à la
fois mythique et très récente puisque la
propriété a réellement explosé il y a
une cinquantaine soit centaine d'années
d'un point de vue
reconnaissant à la fois internationale
et puis et puis françaises il y a deux
événements qui ont aidé à la renommer de
Pétrus tout d'abord le couronnement de
la reine d'Angleterre ou des ou des
Pétrus 47 ont été servis et l'autre
événement aux États-Unis Pétrus est
devenu le vin favori de la de la famille
Kennedy et notamment de JFK qui a été un
ambassadeur de rêve pour pour les vins
de la de la propriété
une histoire récente donc qui est
l'oeuvre d'une femme madame Loubat
propriétaire de Pétrus au début du 20e
siècle et de son partenaire Jean-Pierre
Moueix ils sont les premiers à avoir
décelé le trésor qui était sous leurs
yeux ou plutôt sous leurs pieds
la grande richesse de Pétrus c'est
cette terre très argileuse qui a à peu
près 40 millions d'années qui datent
donc de l'air tertiaire ce sont donc des
alluvions argileuses qui sont
relativement rares à Bordeaux puisque il
y a 120 000 hectares de vignes à
Bordeaux il y a moins de 200 hectares
qui sont exploités sur argile
Pétrus c'est en quelque sorte une
exception dans l'exceptionnelle
alors forcément Olivier porte une
attention toute particulière à ce
vignoble à peine plus de 11 hectares ces
grands terroir il faut pas les
brutaliser il faut les travailler avec
beaucoup douceurs il faut essayer de les
comprendre ça prend ça prend beaucoup de
temps donc il y a un travail mécanique
du sol qui est réalisé pour permettre à
ces argiles de respirer de permettre aux
racines de s'installer bien en
profondeur
ces argiles qui assurent un drainage
unique de l'eau sont entretenus choyés
même jour après jour par Olivier ses
équipes donc on a la chance d'avoir des
hommes qui travaillent sur la propriété
depuis un nombre important d'années et
qui savent comprendre qui savent à quel
moment intervenir
[Musique]
ça va tout va bien
pas de maladie rien du tout vous n'avez
rien de pas de pourriture Pétrus c'est
donc l'histoire d'un seul exceptionnel
un sol mais pas seulement
[Musique]
l'homme que rejoint Olivier c'est son
père Jean-Claude
œnologue chez Petrus pendant 44 ans
à la retraite depuis 2008 il reste
néanmoins le mentor et le conseiller
éclairé d'Olivier chaque fois que
Olivier veut le demande
si les idées de son vieux père lui sont
utiles voilà je viens
tu ressens
c'est vraiment une un échange que l'on a
en permanence donc lui grâce son
demi-siècle d'expérience sur la sur la
propriété donc moi ça son expérience
nourrit mais réflexions pour toujours
faire faire progresser le vignoble le
vin et toujours aller vers une qualité
et une recherche de qualité permanente
vous savez un cru c'est une identité
c'est une personnalité c'est une
typicité et chaque crue est unique donc
tout l'art des responsables c'est de
protéger et de faire exprimer cette
identité cette originalité Pétrus c'est
une rencontre entre un cépage le Merlot
et un sol l'argile qui est quand même
unique en tous les cas à Bordeaux
sa qualité remarquable et remarquée dans
le monde entier Petrus la doit peut-être
aussi à la valeur des hommes qu'il a
façonnent d'abord il faut être modeste
être humble être curieux très
observateur mais être d'une grande
sensibilité également pour bien pour
bien décoder pour bien diagnostiquer la
matière première moi j'ai baigné dans
mon éducation familiale dans la
sensibilité
je pense que finalement c'est la qualité
la plus importante que j'ai peut-être
transmis à mes fils
[Musique]
aux côtés de la famille mouex
propriétaire de Pétrus les bérousets
père et fils veillent sur un domaine à
la réussite discrète et au trésor
silencieux
on a la chance de travailler sur un lieu
qui est mythique avec un produit qui est
absolument extraordinaire et qui nous
procure un plaisir des sensations des
émotions immenses et on met ce vin là
dans une bouteille on sait qu'elle sera
partagée à 10 km d'ici 100 km 10000 ou
20000 km d'ici des personnes vont vous
partager ce moment de plaisir avec leurs
amis leurs familles et on met du bonheur
de la joie en bouteille quelque part
ce jour-là aux côtés d'Olivier nous
avons partagé bien plus qu'un hectare
c'est l'âme de Pétrus que nous avons
caressé
[Musique]
bonjour Pierre bonjour Sophie
président directeur général de Château
d'Yquem vous avez une sacrée
responsabilité si je dis de vous que
vous êtes un peu un chef d'orchestre
est-ce que ça vous va oui ça me va bien
parce que les instruments sont de grande
qualité alors il fallait vraiment un bel
écrin pour les magnifiques nectars que
vous produisez ici il y a un patrimoine
bâti exceptionnel et on le voit bien là
ici dans cette cour le château a une
histoire passionnante un château du lac
principal parti du 17e les murs autour
sont du 15e et là vous avez un
magnifique chez de vieux millésime
d'ycam qui se trouve là et une maison
qui nous permet de recevoir le monde
entier et déjà dans l'histoire
Thomas Jefferson dans les années 1780
était venu ici et avait trouvé le lieu
magique et le vin incroyable et on avait
acheté 300 bouteilles donc voyez on est
vraiment dans l'histoire avec
ikem et on avec le temps et à ce côté
intemporel de ce lieu d'excellence que
j'ai la chance de pouvoir partager avec
une équipe merveilleuse si vous deviez
me parler des trois grands millésimes
d'icam vous choisiriez lesquels
77 37 21 il y a les millésimes 1893
vendanger le 31 août les plus grands
millésimes ils sont à venir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est millésime de légendes
sont quasiment introuvables dans le
commerce alors pour les collectionneurs
et les amateurs le seul moyen de s'en
procurer de fréquenter les salles de
vente aux enchères des salles de vente
qui se transforment parfois en salle au
trésor
[Musique]
à plus de 600 km du Château d'Yquem dans
des hangars de la banlieue parisienne
près de 3000 bouteilles de vin
d'exception attendent de trouver leur
nouveau propriétaire ça c'est la fille
de 70 château cam 99 en magnum château
de la Tour 1955 le 98 alors là c'est les
grands blancs de la Bourgogne un morceau
Perrière 90 des contes lafonds Ariane
Brissard est la responsable du
département 20 et spiritueux de l'étude
d'agent à Paris ce matin-là elle vérifie
une dernière fois l'état des 500 lots
qu'elle proposera aux enchères cet
après-midi à des amateurs venus des
quatre coins de la planète
[Musique]
le clou de la vente 12 lots du vin le
plus mythique de Bourgogne celui du
domaine de la Romanée-Conti
[Musique]
il y a plein de gens qui vont vous dire
j'aimerais boire une bouteille de
Romanée-Conti avant de mourir
ça va être leur rêve
car goûtez un vin du domaine c'est
goûter une histoire séculaire dans
laquelle se croisent les moines de Saint
vivons et le prince de Conti
une histoire dans laquelle s'entrechoque
de rares chefs
6000 bouteilles seulement de
l'appellation Romanée-Conti sont
produites par an
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que j'en ai une
quantité aussi importante on a près de
100 bouteilles en caisse bois d'origine
il y a 12000 qui suivent
oui c'est mon plus beau
[Musique]
Ariane doit transférer jusqu'à l'étude
l'un de ses trésors conservés dans son
écrin une caisse du domaine de la
romanée-contie millésime 2005 une
mission délicate
on va on va mettre les couvertures pour
bien les caler et surtout on sangle pour
pas que ça bouge pendant le transport
et moi les boules mais on se porte
[Musique]
trois quarts d'heure plus tard le lot
485 arrive à bon port
[Musique]
alors que les premiers acheteurs
prennent place dans la salle Ariane et
son équipe vérifient les derniers ordres
d'achat passé par téléphone ou internet
il est 14 heures la vente démarre
la bienvenue pour cette vente consacrée
au grand vins et spirituel avant tu as
été préparé par Ariane Brissard et les
premiers coups de marteau du
commissaire-priseur résonne dans la
salle
j'ai 260
cette jeune femme c'est Paulina Popova
d'origine russe cette grande amatrice de
20 français espèrent remporter pour un
de ses clients une de ces fameuses
caisses du domaine de la Romanée-Conti
13 bouteilles par caisse estimées entre
12 et 20.000 euros
les enchères s'envolent sur Internet
notre lot 485 exposés dans la salle
atteint des sommets
au téléphone
[Applaudissements]
il est 19h et la vente se termine Ariane
a de quoi avoir le sourire les 12
caisses du domaine de la romanée-contie
ont trouvé leur nouveau propriétaire et
vont bientôt voyager à Hong Kong Los
Angeles ou encore Moscou
c'est vraiment un des joyaux des vins
français et parce que c'est ce terroir
qui est microscopique et on fait des
grands vins sur des grands terroirs et
c'est la chance qu'elle a romane et
Conti c'est un terroir exceptionnel
et Paulina Paulina aussi elle sourit le
lot 485 lui a échappé mais elle a obtenu
une caisse de 2007 un peu plus de 25000
euros Pauline a repartira en Russie avec
bien plus que des bouteilles
en fait c'est pas que l'étiquette c'est
pas que grand château en fait derrière
c'est l'histoire c'est le sol c'est
c'est les tiroirs c'est tout ce qui est
autour de vent moi je vais organise de
temps en temps les voyages
gastronomiques pour les clients aussi
particulier et justement quand elle
arrive en France tout d'abord c'est il
faut goûter le vent il faut goûter le
vent il faut goûter le fromage je pense
que c'est vraiment c'est comme la Tour
Eiffel en fait
mais pourquoi Paulina vous-t-elle une
passion un amour immodéré pour ses vins
de Bourgogne nous avons pris une
dernière fois la route pour dénicher ses
trésors qui en Russie et ailleurs font
la grandeur de la France
direction le sud de Dijon et les grands
crus de la Côte de nuit un vignoble aux
identités multiples au rendement modeste
producteur donc des vins les plus chers
au monde
au beau milieu des vignes nous avons
rencontré Vincent Barbier le grand
maître de la confrérie des Chevaliers du
tas de vin chargée de promouvoir et
préserver la culture viticole
bourguignonne je suis né dans le vin et
dans une famille qui était dans la
Confrérie du tas de vin mon grand-père a
été un des fondateurs mon père a
continué donc je me devais de continuer
notre lieu de rendez-vous Vincent le
connaît par cœur
c'était un terrain de jeu quand j'étais
tout petit et puis aujourd'hui c'est
un instrument extraordinaire c'est un
patrimoine formidable quand je rentre au
château je suis ailleurs je pense que
tout se passe bien je crois que le oui
le château est magique
le château dont Vincent parle n'est
autre que le Château du Clos de Vougeot
[Musique]
un édifice du 12e siècle construit au
milieu de 50 hectares de vigne
[Musique]
un grand cru que se partage aujourd'hui
80 propriétaires
[Musique]
Vincent nous emmène découvrir les
trésors de ce symbole quasi millénaire
de l'histoire des vins de Bourgogne
voilà nous sommes dans le grand cellier
cistercien grands Cellier du Château du
Clos de Vougeot monument très important
puisque construit au début du 12e siècle
et c'est là que les moines de sitôt
élevaient conservaient leurs vins les
plus précieux on pouvait empiler jusqu'à
2000 tonneaux
[Musique]
cisterciens ont leur abbaye à une
quinzaine de kilomètres du clos
dès le Moyen-âge les ducs de Bourgogne
leur font dons de multiples vignes
les moines de sitôt deviennent alors de
véritables vignerons
ce cellier était remplacé la cave
puisque nous sommes sur un banderoche et
les moines avec les techniques de
l'époque n'ont pas pu construire de
caves enfin creuser de caves ils ont
donc construit ce cellier qui en partie
enterré puisque on voit les vignes à peu
près à ce niveau là
[Musique]
aux côtés des bénédictins de l'abbaye de
Cluny les moines de sitôt donnent alors
vain une véritable identité
ils associent alors parcelles cépage
terroir et savoir-faire ce sont les
fameux Climats de Bourgogne ces mêmes
climats qui ont été classés en 2015
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
ils inventent également la notion de
clos qui permet par un mur d'enceinte de
déterminer plus précisément la propriété
des terres et éviter les vols le Clos de
Vougeot en est une solide illustration
c'est là vraiment qui est née la
Bourgogne et les grands vins de
Bourgogne puisque les moines avaient le
savoir et la durée c'est ça qui est
formidable savoir parce que ils avaient
des livres et il a duré parce que parce
que il plantait un endroit si ça ne
marchait pas ils analysaient pas la
terre il la goûtait mais mais il voyait
bien ce que ça donnait donc la durée a
été quelque chose de très important
puisque les moines sont restés ici dans
ce château qu'ils ont construit pendant
plus de six siècles
siècle appréciècle les moines de sitôt
vont organiser structurer le vignoble de
Bourgogne ils vont alors s'équiper comme
en témoignent un impressionnant vestige
conservés dans la cuverie du Château du
Clos de Vougeot
alors tout à l'heure je parlais de magie
et bien nous y sommes en plein dans la
magie puisque nous sommes devant le
pressoir construit en 1477
près de six siècles plus tard se
pressoir et toujours en activité
c'est des chaînes de la forêt de sitôt
qui ont été coupés ils avaient 250 ans
ils sont restés encore 200 ans dans
l'eau
parce que c'était le meilleur moyen pour
les garder imputrescible après ils ont
séché et ils ont été mis en oeuvre donc
on va dire la tradition raconte que sont
les chaînes qui ont été plantées on va
dire à l'époque de Charlemagne en l'an
800 c'est une partie d'histoire de
France bien sûr
cette histoire de France les moines de
sitôt vont continuer à l'écrire en
érigeant à côté de l'édifice du 12e
siècle un manoir Renaissance
confisqué à la révolution au titre de
bien national le Château du Clos de
Vougeot sera transformé abandonné puis
restaurer au gré de ses nouveaux
propriétaires
madame messieurs nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir au sein de
notre aujourd'hui ce joyau architectural
est le siège de la confrérie des
Chevaliers du tas de vin près d'une fois
par mois Vincent barbier et officie avec
son habit de grand maître pour
introniser de nouveaux membres
barbacus dieu du vin et par
Saint-Vincent patron des vignerons nous
armons chevaliers du tas de vin
12000 chevaliers au total dont la moitié
d'étrangers tous animés par ce goût pour
un patrimoine unique aux couleurs de la
Bourgogne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
unique c'est ce qui caractérise le
domaine le roi à Vosne-Romanée
si ces 20 figurent parmi les plus
recherchés et appréciés au monde il le
doivent à s'approprier un personnage
iconoclaste de 85 ans qui répond au nom
poétiques de la Loue le roi
[Musique]
ça c'est la Bourgogne
regarde comme il est beau ouais 2 3 4 5
c'est super
c'est aussi comme une personne la terre
la terre elle vit
elle est bonne elle sent bon
elle est belle Lalou est infatigable
quand elle parle de ses vignes elle en
prend soin comme de ses enfants
[Musique]
adeptes de la biodynamie depuis la
création de son domaine en 1988 la loupe
délaisse par exemple la technique du
rognage afin de renforcer l'immunité de
la plante c'est une liane la vigne c'est
une liane alors l'apprivoiser d'accord
mais la garder quand même avec des vrais
qui savent s'accrocher partout et pas la
renier et l'estropier
les petits raisins sont beaux regardez
ils sont jolies c'est des petits raisins
qui font le meilleur vin c'est pas les
gros raisins
on imagine on perçoit déjà le vin comme
il sera
la loupe prodiga sa terre et ses pieds
de vigne des soins dont elle a le secret
aucun pesticides aucun herbicide que des
composts des préparations biodynamiques
et des tisanes pulvérisées à même le dos
par de vaillants employés
nous invite à découvrir une pièce
inhabituelle chez un vigneron son
officine derrière et bien ce sont toutes
mes tisanes mais des coques les plantes
qui me servent tout au long de l'année
l'origan qui est comme ça c'est le futur
antibiotique lorsque nous antibiotiques
ne marcheront plus c'est l'origan parce
que c'est très antibactérien moi j'en
prends tout le temps aussi j'ai de
lasses mais j'en prends tout le temps ça
me fait du bien du reste j'essaie tout
sur moi avant comme ça
la rhubarbe très très efficace contre
les tout ce qui est champignons donc ils
attaques de mildiou Audium blackrotte
c'est extraordinaire
romarin quand il fait froid dans un coup
de chaud
on leur donne des forces de vie on les
empêche d'être malade et on les renforce
et on les veut belle on les veut jolie
et
heureuse voilà
allez les bébés on vous le disait la
Loue est un personnage iconoclaste ses
collaborateurs dont Frédéric le plus
proche doivent composer avec un
caractère bien trempé
c'est mal fagoté et nouveau objet à tout
arrangé il est où le fret et voilà
encore un conscrit là
quand est-ce qu'elle vient à Katia
beauty
Fred viens voir il faut que tu mettes
que tu viennes m'aider Fred viens voir
m'aider regarde moi ça
tu vois bien qu'elle est souffre
celle-là
croiser c'est natté
faudrait pas m'emmener trop loin dans
Mes Vignes parce que je vais
t'emmerdeuse
nous avons eu nous aussi droit à notre
lot de remarque bon bah on y va j'arrive
ah mais non il continue toujours
mes allumages de ces vins la loubise le
roi c'est aussi se rendre séduisante et
généreuse mais moi j'ai de la chance que
d'abord j'ai Fred qui comprend qui qui
m'aide beaucoup beaucoup
et puis quand même qui avec les gars et
qui les encourage quand ça va parce que
bon
je suis pas très patiente non plus des
fois
je vous ai préparé un bon coq
beaucoup couvain et puis on va bien
manger j'ai tout préparé tout est prêt
bon où est Fred
tu vas pas dans l'eau
à l'heure du déjeuner nous avons donc
goûté ce fameux coq au vin du domaine
bien sûr énième moment
d'authenticités
c'est magique
cette intimité que nous avons eu le
privilège de partager nous avons voulu
la graver lors d'une conversation
improvisée pour connaître les
motivations de celles que l'on peut
aujourd'hui considérer comme un
véritable trésor vivant
j'ai été baptisé enfin un quart d'heure
après ma naissance mon père m'a mis sur
les lèvres bien sûr je me rappelle plus
quelques gouttes de musini 29
je suis né dans le vin j'ai aimé levain
j'ai été élevée dans le respect du vrai
dans l'amour du vin sans mon père
j'aurais rien pu faire parce que mon
père était extraordinaire d'abord de me
laisser faire une gamine de 23 ans
la Loue nous confie qu'elle a travaillé
pendant 30 ans aux côtés de ce père
qu'elle vénère négociant en vain et
copropriétaire du domaine de la
Romanée-Conti jusqu'à ce qu'elle décide
de constituer son propre domaine
ce que je savais c'est que je voulais
produire des vins tels que je les rêver
depuis toujours tel que je les ai
cherché tout au long de ma carrière
[Musique]
son village les habitants du village le
passé du village
et voilà le vin et le miroir de l'homme
tout à fait c'est ça
avec son humilité paysanne lalouise le
roi n'aimerait certainement pas
contempler ses vins elle y verrait
pourtant de véritables chefs que le
monde entier brûle de déguster toutes
mes dégustations a toujours été à la
gloire de la Bourgogne pas forcément à
la gloire de le roi à la gloire de la
Bourgogne vraiment vraiment
parce que c'est
c'est énorme je me rends bien compte que
c'est énorme comme patrimoine
[Musique]
modeste en superficie ce patrimoine
viticole de Bourgogne est effectivement
énorme en prestige et en histoire
en témoigne le Château du Clos de
Vougeot bien sûr
[Musique]
l'abbaye de Cîteaux
le palais des ducs de Bourgogne à Dijon
ou encore les Hospices de Beaune dont
les illustres vont aux enchères
rassemblent les touristes et amateurs de
vins du monde entier
[Musique]
20 mythiques château extraordinaire la
main de l'homme a façonné des trésors
inestimables que le monde entier nous
envie la main de l'homme bien sûr mais
aussi cette terre une terre nourricière
qui ici à château d'ycam comme dans tous
les autres domaines que nous avons eu la
chance de découvrir aujourd'hui et
certainement le trésor le plus précieux
ce patrimoine exceptionnel du vignoble
français nous a été légué il y a des
siècles il nous appartient donc de le
cultiver de le protéger pour que jamais
ne disparaisse c'est trésors
[Musique]